a wedding that a suicide bomber turned
into a massacre these people are waiting
to hear whether their relatives and
friends survived I'm here to find out
about my son
to find out if he's okay some people say
that his neck is injured
some people say his hand is injured he's
not answering his phone I don't know
what to do more than 1,000 people were
at the wedding for a young couple from
Afghan Shia Muslim minority the Hazara
the marriage certificate had just been
signed when an ISIL suicide attacker
wearing a vest packed with explosives
detonated them near the stage I was at
the back of the wedding hall when
suddenly a big explosion happened I fell
down and when I stood up I saw tables
and people scattered on the ground the
scene was awful my brother was injured
most of my friends were killed I didn't
know at that time what to do
who should I help first in shock Saki
hasn't moved from this spot all night at
another hospital
we found Zarif 14 hours after the
explosion he woke from his coma as we
filmed he was the lead singer and
keyboard player in the wedding band when
we leave her home in the morning we
don't know if he'll come back alive if
we send our children to school we do not
know their fate we don't trust any
security even at a wedding this can
happen I do not know if we'll be alive
in an hour or not Sharif's band was made
up of seven family members his brothers
and cousins they were on stage preparing
to play during the wedding dinner when
the bomb went off the reef is the only
survivor and this is what he would have
played at the wedding hall staff cleaned
up they mopped the ground not the
spilled drink but the spilled blood
they lost colleagues too with dozens
killed any Lee 200 injured this was the
deadliest explosion in Kabul in more
than 18 months
cerise family brought us to a hill
overlooking the city here is where the
band's drummer Mohammad Hanifa
was buried just hours earlier
turn on robbing officers in chuga no
moss why should we be killed
it's for nothing what is our sin what
have we done wrong we feed our children
and ISIL is killing us without
committing a crime we asked the
government why they aren't stopping them
ISIL has claimed responsibility for the
attack it often targets Shia minority in
this neighborhood with elections just
six weeks away president Ghani is under
pressure and has called an emergency
security meeting whether Taliban also
commented calling the attack barbaric
forbidden and unjustifiable well Afghan
leaders in the Taliban lay blame
children lay on their relatives graves
too young to understand the forces that
turned a day of joy into one of tragedy
Charlotte Bellis al Jazeera Kabul